not today oh wrong wrong sound settings give me a sec all
right there you go not today not today dragons oh yes I am
very much awake because I had to take us oh shit oh husky
twitch and youtube thank you so much man I really appreciate
it but not today Not today.
I am on time yet again.
Not just on time, but one minute early.
That's right.
No website is gonna get me.
I knew you, Dragoons, were gonna be like, if I started at 5,
I'm sorry, at 1230 or at exactly 5, you'd be like, um,
actually, Doki.
you are 0.0 5, 7, 8, 6 seconds late.
Not today.
I bypass your fucking calculations by being one minute
early.
Actually, Doki, actually 45 seconds but I wasn't late.
I was not late.
And that's all that matters.
You're 0.0.
001 check it late dokey we got you caught on the camera
caught on the website but did you expect this though it's
okay we're patient it'll happen yeah but you have two more
days this i have two more days two more days till i'm free
and i'll be late on tuesday and it's simple thank you for
Thank you.
And you're not Mundo.
What's like a joke is this?
You know what's funny?
After the stream, I finished the game because I wanted to
know the ending.
The ending sucked, by the way.
The ending, like, I guess, like, it's an idle game.
So, like, you're really, like, how are they going to make an
ending for that?
But I actually finished the game.
Because I was, I was like, I was like one death away anyway.
So I was just like, fuck it.
Let's just see what the ending gives me.
I just want, okay.
And also because I just want to keep, well, I wanted to keep
scratching but in a way I just wanted to just kept cashing
in the lottery tickets I automated everything I just let
Mondo do all the work I just like go Mondo go I think it was
super chat thank you thank you thank you remember girlfriend
covers only 2k away from 1 million thank you the super chat
oh thank you thank you oh my god are you serious it's 2k um
jk i knew it because today i was supposed to release the
streaming services for a girlfriend and then um but there
was like a miscommunication with me and one of my staff
members uh because i was like oh release the files the
girlfriend files onto the internet and then and then and
then she was like um it's not ready and i was like what do
you mean it's not ready i thought when you
ready to go on streaming services.
She was like, yes, it's ready to be approved to go on
streaming services.
And I was just like, oh, okay, can you process that now?
And she was like, it takes two to three weeks to approve
Dokey.
And I was like, oh, oh, I don't.
So in two to three weeks starting today, the files will be
released into the streaming service world.
I, so, oops, I was like, nice, we timed it perfectly, we
timed it perfectly to get for one million, and then,
unfortunately, it'll be in two to three weeks after a
million, that, oops, so, uh, so we'll, we'll be there, we'll
be there, and we'll get there, at least it's, it's now going
through the process now.
It's going through the process at the moment.
It's confirmed to go through it today.
Bird, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Why am I bribing dad for if I got you arrived here on time?
You know he plays both sides.
Never trust him.
Don't trust those eyes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Little did you know, Doki, we're training you to be early.
A good streamer should be.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Duck, fine.
I'll start measuring it in nanoseconds.
Thank you for the super chat.
Duck, thank you.
Thank you.
Anya, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can't stick around for this one, so I just want to drop by
and say hi and crack, so I'm not being late.
Yay, the bare minimum of a streamer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
At least, I saw, I see some streamers.
Even when they start the stream on time, there would be like
a 15 to 30 minute plus starting screen.
At least, you know, I don't do that, right?
I once made it 10 minutes, but like, but at least it didn't
go to 30 minutes.
True.
Juge, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
It's the, you know, it's the,
you know, it's those, it's those little moments, you know,
they add up.
It's just, well, watch, don't give her ideas.
Juge, thank you, thank you, thank you for streaming Halo 2
today.
This makes me happy.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you I realized that I haven't had an afternoon stream
of Halo 2 yet So I figured that in I don't know if I'll be
streaming Like I guess I've been doing a lot of okay I've
been trying to do smaller streams, but because I like I said
it's I've been going through hell April hell today Not today
for like this month So uh, I will try to not stream too long
today because I need a rest My voice today.
But I do realize that we are getting close to the end.
So I hope we can finish it by Saturday.
That's my goal there.
Also, what else do I want to tell you guys?
Oh yes, I almost fixed my sleep schedule.
And by almost, yesterday I didn't take a nap.
I slept at 5 in the morning, but that is improvement.
You know, I didn't sleep at 8 in the morning.
I slept at 5 a.m.
today which is a lot better than what it was yesterday so
didn't take any naps and I also didn't sleep after eight so
it's progress we're slowly getting there progress is
progress so yippee what else what else I want to update you
guys on or talk about champions thing i don't know if it's
supposed to be bad or good because i hear people like
talking a lot about uh like like ranking a lot on pokemon
champions but for those who don't know what pokemon
champions is um i as i don't know really into competitive
pokemon but i saw a lot of people complaining about it on my
timeline and then it was apparently the first time where i
was that one of the main guys for the Sererby, Sererby's,
Sererby, sorry, the Sererby website.
The Sererby website is basically, like, the Pokemon
information website about everything.
And then he was like, I can't even defend this anymore.
Like, he was like, this is ass.
And everyone's like, oh my god, the Sererby dev actually
called it ass.
What the fuck?
so like like people were so surprised because he was like
you know the ultimate like fan like the ultimate pokemon um
i don't i don't say fanboy but you know like like like the
pokemon expert type deal because he literally runs uh he
literally runs like the serabi website for like what 20 plus
years or some shit or i don't know 15 plus years i've lost
track of how long pokemon's been around it's like it's been
a while uh yeah but like one the um the pokemon expert
representatives he literally finished pocapea in what two
days or some shit two to three days and everyone was like
holy fucking a life and people were like you do know like
this is his life this is his job We were like telling the
Seravi website guy to like get a life and people were like,
um, this is his, this is literally his job.
Like, he is here to document everything related to Pokemon.
He has to finish the game to write a guide about it on the
website.
Um, yeah, he's literally the Pokemon guy.
Uh, but yeah, I don't, I don't know much about Pokemon
champions.
I just was like reading it because everyone it was like
apparently next hyped release um It was the next hyped
release Uh And so especially like to follow I guess like you
know following up pokepia Some people are like whoa They did
so well with pokepia I can't wait to see how well they do
for pokemon champions I guess if pokemon champions didn't
have to follow up with pokepia with the expectations it had
Um it would I feel like it might not have like got as much
as much like screwing as it did but apparently a lot of
people were like like I guess the more competitive players
were just not that happy about it because they changed a lot
of like they changed a lot of abilities and yeah they
changed a lot of abilities and there was a lot and then it
was like super buggy and everything and so people were like
really upset about it the competitors side I thought casual
people were fine because they don't I guess like the more
casual players didn't know like the changes Like you know
they they're not like that into the they're like they're not
used to the competitive side So they don't know what's
different, but Yeah, apparently it's like a ranking it's a
PvP Pokemon game So you're actually having Pokemon fights
with other actual players who owns a switch to
Who owns But also, it's very limited, because, you know, you
gotta want to switch to play the game.
Colin, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Finally get to watch the stream.
No, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah, apparently there's not a lot of Pokemon, too.
There's not a lot of Pokemans.
Oh, it can be played on Switch 1.
Oh, nice.
That's great.
I thought they said they were...
I thought I read something about how they weren't playing.
planning on making more games on the switch one uh but i
didn't guess it didn't start yet like it doesn't start yet
because eventually they're gonna stop like making games for
it um because like you know they got they got promote sales
on the switch too oh it's coming mobile i mean i feel like
on mobile it's gonna uh it's gonna do really well I know our
mobile is going to do really fucking well because like you
know uh you could just imagine getting beat by someone who's
just sitting in their toilet just be like I can sneak one
game in like usually that's how it goes in the bathroom like
I can sneak one game in like um yeah I most likely by the
mobile release still patch everything up but that's crazy
though that they messed up uh like abilities and stuff too i
saw like a video i didn't understand it at first that like
the competitive side uh was really mad about it was
something about how um like i think it was like last choice
was doing sprout spout or something and then the uh melodic
did like a haze ability and it wasn't supposed to heal that
much but it healed like almost the entire HP and people
competitive people were like how dare they and I was like
what's going on because I don't know any about I don't know
anything about those moves I was like I was confused and
then yeah yeah I was just like I have to read those and then
when I understood it I was like how dare they
yeah i was just like oh my god how dare it at first i was
like what the i don't understand what's going on
yeah it's not supposed to heal but then it like healed or
some shit and the movie is like what the fuck i'm upset that
you're upset all right but yeah anyway let's go play hello
hello time i mean
oh fuck okay sorry uh i just got notified uh about something
i'm just like ah okay more work it's Remember the tunnel?
The tunnel got further even further.
They like dug.
They extended the tunnel.
They dug more into the tunnel.
They dug.
Like I was like, okay, I know where the tunnel ends.
And it's going to end here.
And then they're like, sorry, we extended the tunnel.
Like we dug more.
So you got to go through a bit more.
You'll understand.
I know I keep saying it, but y'all understand soon, dragons.
Y'all understand.
Okay, let me reply to this one real quick.
All right.
I'm sorry.
I have to reply to this word message real quick.
After getting the news, I need clarification on exactly how
much...
yeah
all right there you go okay now now we play halo okay unless
i get another work message and then and then we unless
another work message decides to pop up now we play halo also
sound guy um i might need i don't know if sound guy is here
uh but uh i think i forgot to save the sound I know I know
it keeps happening It keeps It keeps happening I think I'm
not sure I might I might need To double check for me Alright
let's see I think it was this We're going by feeling right
now I think I'm feeling that it was this So sound guy I need
confirmation Soon all right anyway now is now now is halo I
didn't tweet that is live.
It's because I tweeted like five minutes ago before the
stream was about to start That with the waiting room So then
I was like I don't think I need to tweet that I'm live
because the waiting room literally came out like in five
minutes before the stream Starts So I was just like I think
people would know that I'm live Because it's usually used as
a reminder if the waiting room was posted a lot earlier but
like the reminder is the waiting room
all right let's get me signed in because i don't remember
okay that's cool all right i'm in all right here we go oh
whoa whoa whoa all
right resume i have to listen to that before i start it's to
inspire me it's like my or this is like my war cry please
stand for the national anthem i okay all right now i'm here
now i'm where now i'm here okay i have to like remember
where now is all right i killed a regret so um no regrets
teammate okay
Wait, these are bad guys.
What the fuck are they?
Why are they bad guys?
How are they a baddie?
Wait, am I an alien?
Fuck!
I forgot!
Oh, what the fuck?
Whoops.
I forgot now I'm a baddie.
Now I have to go back to...
That's why I was like, he's...
See, guys, the reprogramming worked.
I told you I could get out of my reprogramming.
I didn't shoot first and ask questions later when I saw a
filthy alien.
See, guys?
I can be fixed.
I wonder if I can destroy this.
So...
proud of you.
Thank you.
I worked very hard for that.
I assume I'm just supposed to...
Can we just be spawning?
I wonder.
See, I didn't shoot first and ask questions later.
Oh, there we go.
I just assumed that it was just survival.
Oh, well, I didn't realize it closed.
I...
I know, knock knock.
Can I be let in as well?
It's like too slow.
It actually went too slow.
Well, I'm sorry.
I didn't realize it'll close on me.
Oh, they spawned forever.
Oh my god, how the fuck do I?
How did I do this last time?
It just opened.
What do you mean?
It literally just opened.
Open!
Oh my god, that's all I have to do.
It changed color!
It...
Open!
Get, let me in!
Oh, my, there we go.
There we go.
It opened.
How the fuck?
Oh, I could have.
I could have grabbed stuff there.
Alright, it opened.
It took a while, but it opened.
It opened.
Sesame!
Is it gonna open?
Oh, yeah.
Everything's punched.
Oh, my God.
It's a double knock.
It's like a fucking secret handshake or something.
It's like I'm at the club.
It's like, what's the secret knock?
What's the...
What's the fucking...
Do the very specific knock to open the fucking door?
Knock, knock.
What's the secret hand shake?
Dokey.
Fucking double tap.
How was I supposed to know it was a goddamn double tap?
You don't know the secret knock, dokey?
Wow.
Everyone knows the secret knock.
Anybody knows it.
Knock.
There you go.
Are you fucking...
I'm trying to do a secret knock right now.
Not a real bro.
Okay, nice.
That's the evil alien, right?
Or is that my...
Oh, that's my teammate.
I should help him.
Alright.
my teammates see didn't shoot first I'm here your hero is
here the wrong password don't worry your hero is here nobody
panicked there was nothing to panic about if you were not
panicking do not worry continue to not panic i should use
that gun
like i wasn't panicking anyway what do you mean
no one panic stop panicking everyone
all right i'm ready to do the secret handshake again
Please, remain calm.
Knock, knock.
There we go.
The library's so good.
Where's the library?
This is the library.
I don't even know where I'm at.
I don't know.
I don't even know this is the library.
I lost track.
This could be the library.
This is library-esque.
It's literally the sequel.
I should help them.
See, look at that.
I helped them.
Knock.
What?
Oh, I have to knock on this side.
Trottinger's Library.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, whoops.
They're like, wait till it loses interest.
How the fuck did he know?
He's walling.
Oh, there's no way he knows now.
I'm actually in the shadows.
I just don't know where he's looking at.
Wait, where is he?
see oh wait a minute where did he go oh there he is i was
like he's a big boy how the fuck
i don't know if that was considered his back it was back
adjacent
i was just like it's back adjacent it's the side oh there's
the back It's a pack like Use grenades I don't know if I'll
hit it
He's so He just slowly turns I don't have any charge Oh
There we go There we go I got his sides guys I did it So see
I have his own special gun Imagine imagine we can just hold
this this fucking holds that all right pop pop why double
knocked what more do you want
oh it's not this then maybe it wasn't that there we go
and then oh my god oh my i how how
There you go.
Okay.
Oh, I'm sorry that I'm one I'm one frame too far away.
Like, what the fuck?
Okay.
Powering it.
Too close.
It was a triple knock all along.
See, after that, you gotta know the secret, the ultra secret
hands, the handshake.
Only real bros know what it is.
The secret secret club underneath the original secret club.
Oh, that's pretty.
Oh, wait, I'm out of...
Oh!
Look, there's the planet over there.
There is Hado!
Wait, that's my ship.
Sorry.
Oh shit, wait.
Oh no.
Oh fuck.
Wait, shoot them, not me!
Oh shit!
Oh no, they breached You breached the walls.
Quick!
Go put the wall in rows.
Well, that was my last name.
And I missed.
And she missed.
Alright, it's cool.
I have a frag grenade.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Why are you chasing me?
Oh, now it's library.
now we're here yeah this feels more laborious now maybe
they'll hurt each other I'm gonna wait for them to hurt each
other a bit more I don't know they're shooting at me okay
nice all right all right we'll let them have their little
fight I'll stay here for a little bit is this infinite are
the are the the zombies infinite or like am I free to go
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'll see you guys later.
I don't know where the door is.
Where do I do my secret handshake?
Oh,
no.
Is this Halo infinite?
I have to destroy something.
Oh, it's a big boy.
Maybe they'll destroy.
him for me.
Okay, that's fine.
They don't know.
Oh, there we go.
I did.
Okay, I don't... I think that's just... Wait.
Unless...
Okay, no.
That's just where they spawn.
Don't worry.
Maybe he'll see the aliens up here.
And then...
Okay, I'll just grab this.
You guys can continue to shoot each other.
I'm wrong.
door don't worry they're still shooting at each other oh my
god why why me okay
all right that's right get out of here okay that's right
oh my god i see it Okay, I got the big boy.
Big boy down!
Do you want me?
Oh, God.
All right.
Oh, wait.
I still need to let...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, my God.
This goddamn sorry, Abib.
my god i'm cornered oh my god i'm cornered i'm trying to do
the loop the loop oh whatever it's a pistol tab
all right
are you fucking whoa
oh fight fight each other fuck this i'm out all right
handshake tab one two stereo goodbye you guys can fight each
other this is not my war i'm just here i just want to read
oh my god this piss sucks oh this is bad
i might have to die to the okay
it's fine it's fine knock and die
All right.
Oh, I thought they would go somewhere else.
Not gonna lie.
I thought this would go somewhere else.
But.
Knock.
I'm missing my knocks.
I'm missing my knock.
Knock.
No, knock, knock, knock, knock, knock, knock, four knocks
this time.
Four knocks.
Okay, you're not just, get out of here.
Okay, thank God.
All right, now I have a shotgun.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
I have to use human guns.
Human gun time.
Let's slide to the left.
Slide to the right.
Two hops this time.
Oh shit.
I feel like...
How much ammo?
Okay, I'm gonna get the SMG.
Oh shit.
Oh my god!
Just like, I feel like this...
Okay, cloak time.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
They do so much damage.
Oh my god.
How many shots?
I need a...
Okay.
Alright, these guys think it's fine.
They can do their little jig if they want.
Alright.
There we go.
you don't oh my god oh oh okay that's fine let them fight
each other first before i do anything oh wait you want to
fight me all right that's cool that's cool i wanted you to
fight the other guys that's cool
all right let's just leave let's just leave all right you
know
what oh fuck that's not I needed myself
accidentally made it myself maybe
oh shit I tried a grenade jump earlier wait oh you cannot be
fucking with me no no I fucked up I played I fucked around
and found out oh my Oh my god!
I actually fucked around and found out.
Oh, I didn't realize!
I didn't realize it'll take me back!
What the fuck I wanted the ray gun?
Okay, I actually fucked around and found out.
I'm just gonna Do this
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god, I didn't see this guy.
Alright, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Now give me the goddamn beam.
Just keep running, just keep running, just keep running.
It will not be okay.
Woo!
Whoa!
Oh shit!
It will not be okay.
There you go.
Just keep running.
Just how to keep...
There we go.
See?
Everything is fine.
All right.
I might need this new gun.
All right, see?
Knock.
There we go.
It worked.
It worked, guys.
All right, they're fighting each other.
fighting each other i just need to figure out left or right
all
right i'm in i'm in oh okay wait
um all right that was the extent of my plan this is nothing
All right.
What is plan B, you might add?
That's the funny part.
There was no plan B.
Good plan.
Wait.
Ah, I did look.
I poked him.
That's right.
him a little poke.
Is this where I'm supposed to be?
Hey.
Whoa.
Let me go into this little hidey hole now.
Grab that.
I'm lost.
They made this like a fucking goddamn maze.
Oh, hey.
This is a goddamn maze.
Okay, it must be here.
Oh my god, knock!
There we go.
Knock, knock, knock!
Knock!
Six knocks this time.
Oh, you thought I didn't see you there?
Oh my god, I didn't even see him in the other graphics.
He was right.
Oh, I don't like this one.
One bit.
I don't know if I like this.
What the fuck?
What is that gonna do?
For you.
Oh my god, they're actually just trying to sneak up to me.
I should just move on.
Oh, he almost got it.
Get out of here!
He just left.
Okay, maybe this way?
Okay.
Alright, someone should really pay the bills.
For this place.
Okay, that's not good.
I go invisible now.
I don't feel so good.
I'm about to grab the...
Oh, fuck.
Alright.
Am I supposed to go?
I might actually have to grab the laser now.
I ran out of bullets.
Knock.
What the?
Oh my god, the popcorn.
Knock.
There you go.
I'm here for the party.
This is a very...
to the party, guys.
Alright, checkpoint done.
A lot longer than I expected.
I thought we were gonna party!
Knock.
Alright.
Is there anything cool?
No?
Alright, I'll go down.
Whoa!
Most intense slide I've ever had.
Yay!
Guys, I don't need more weapons.
I got my rocket launcher and my laser.
Don't keep acting the exact opposite of a cannon arm.
Thank you for the super chat, Lolly.
Thank you, thank you.
Wee!
I'm just hoping they'll kill each other, right?
Oh, oh, whoa!
Whoa, I said it.
each other.
I'm not part of that.
Knock.
I mean, there's a sword, so.
Look at this.
I'm grabbing this.
Whee!
The secret slide's a secret, secret base.
Throw your hands in the air.
Makes it look like you go faster.
Yeah!
Hey!
Huh?
Alright.
I gotta change because I can't see.
Oh my god, I actually can't see.
I have to play on this graphics.
I'll think they'll see me, right?
Oh, where did I go?
Oh shit!
Where did I go?
You think they know?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
I just started swinging.
You know what?
What's that guy in particular?
I don't think I'm supposed to go into this pit.
I'm very tempted, though.
I really am.
I just went to the pit.
Oh yeah.
You know, my dead body went.
Oh no.
Alright.
That was my bad.
I might have loitered a bit too much.
They decided for me.
I don't know why I did that.
I saw a big boy.
I saw a big boy and then I took the shot.
We'll be fine.
So, wait, just in case.
Wee!
Oh, fuck you.
Alright.
I made it.
Because I'm not the door.
I hope the guy's okay.
Oh, I got security area.
Oh, shit.
Alright guys, let me help you guys.
Alright, I'm getting up.
That was not useful.
That was not useful at all.
I'm securing the area.
Nice.
We're doing it, boys.
we oh that does nothing how do i get out of here
guys let's go can i swap swords with you what are you doing
here can we swap swords
what if we like touch our sword tips
all right Okay, we will chase them someday.
We'll make it.
There we go.
Oh my god, they take so little sword bullets.
Live on stream?
What if our swords touch?
Unless.
Oh shit, we wanted to cut two.
Oh, I might need to go invisible for a little bit.
A little hit and run there.
What is he shooting at?
That one?
Okay, he's got this, right?
That's right.
Threat neutralized.
Alright, I think I should have to look it.
Because I feel like if I don't, I'm just going to save for
Halo Infinite.
Oh, there he is.
Come on, get down from here!
Nice.
Ow.
Oh, shit.
Oh, oh, it's just a little guy.
It's five.
Chop.
There you go.
Swap swords.
Got recharged.
Recharge!
Chop!
Oh, there's two more chops!
I have two more chops in me!
Wait, where are they?
Are they from above?
Get down from here!
Hey!
There we go.
Get in here, soldier!
Is he okay?
He's okay.
Oh, shit!
Okay, they shot at me.
I was like, wait, is that the enemy ship?
It was my ship.
Rude.
I know.
I was like, that's fucking rude.
In the center of this zone is a sacred icon critical to the
great journey.
I must...
Sorry, there was a bug on you.
We shall cut into the heart of this infestation, retrieve
the icon, and burn any flood that stands in our way.
The parasite is not to be trifled with.
I hope you know what you're doing.
Forward, warriors, and fear not pain or death.
Oh, it's just...
I'll follow when I reach out.
Oh.
Woo!
All right, go do your thing!
Oh, my God, I got my own army now.
That's fucking right.
Onward.
Onward, my men.
Okay, I can't do anything.
I can just drive.
Go, man.
We're special forces now.
FBI.
Open up.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Where do we go?
Bum, bum, bum.
War, war, war, oh, whoa, whoa, war.
That's right.
Thank God I'm driving.
Yes, thank God I'm driving.
Thank God.
Okay, wait, no, I actually have to drive.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get out.
I had, I have to drive.
Yeah, I did.
Okay, how the fuck, how was I supposed to know I'm gonna get
nuked?
Beow, beow, beow, beowow, beowow.
Fire.
Oh, shit.
Where's the pathway?
All right.
I have to find the pathway.
It's very hard to see.
I don't know if that...
Oh, shit.
That's not...
Oh, my God!
Fade Slay!
It's a Godhead Fade Slay time.
Oh, shit!
This is the wrong place to get off the car.
Men!
Men, I need you guys to get high.
Oh, God!
okay we're it's here wait wait which way did i die okay it's
i couldn't tell i don't know which way i i didn't have any
That was the worst fight.
I drove through 80 sections and I didn't hit any checkpoint.
What the fuck is this bullshit?
How did the fucking zombies know how to drive now?
Where did they get their license?
Where the fuck did these guys get their license chat?
All right, it's fine.
The parasites can now drive.
They know how, okay, knowing, I don't think, no, they're not
actually like shooting, shooting.
Oh my god, they're literally operating the tank too.
I just noticed that.
My god.
Okay, okay, we hit a check.
point though thank God guess it's as fast as my fucking car
can go the DMV will give license to anyone now not a true as
long as you wait that live okay now I know the pathway
though it's here there's a rocket in front of me.
I just noticed the rocket.
I just noticed that the guitar is going fucking crazy.
I'll get there eventually.
Except there's literally a rocket launcher.
What can't I do about it?
I'm jukeing it as much as I can.
Which is like surprisingly not as much as I would like.
Okay there we go.
There we go.
Get jukeed.
Oh.
Fuck.
Oh, fuck.
It jukeed.
Oh, no.
No, no.
I'm lost now.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
I see it.
Get up.
No.
Oh, my God.
I'm blocking the only exit.
Goodbye, my men.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
You died with honor.
Bye,
my fellow men.
Don't worry.
I'll tell your families that you died very honorably.
Oh, is that another...
Terminal time.
Yeah, Lord time!
I left them there to secure the area, chat.
I didn't leave them to die.
They are securing the area.
It is most unusual that in all the exploits of these
arbiters, you never mentioned their role in choosing their
missions of redemption.
There is no role, Oracle.
Once one of our commanders becomes an orbiter, he belongs to
the Hierarchs.
These Hierarchs, they are the same high prophets who control
all the holy relics you collect from my time the same and
they use these relics to build your new weapons and bring
you the word of your gods it has always been so interesting
am I a holy relic I do not wait so holy relics are just
technology oh the religion is false as is this mining
platform you stand upon as was the installation that once
orbited the planet the forerunners technology is lasting and
indeed quite powerful but I'm quite certain they would have
told me if I was infused with some kind of oh my god it
can't be I suspect some of your prophets may have been aware
of how much it's not magic tools such as myself it's just
science and you never question heretic ever question
questioning was what brought shame to the word arbiter long
ago oracle it was silent science all along we should have
been asking for a long long time they're just like happy to
answer any such questions but i have a few more for you
continue your tale of these arbiters
and then they bring out a Glock.
My pair of bullets will stop this.
I can't believe it.
So that's how they won.
I was gonna say last playthrough, I was like, how the fuck
did the war aliens lose to the prayer aliens?
But it wasn't prayer.
It was just science.
They They were the science aliens!
Also, I'm lost.
I think I looped the looped.
Is it here?
Oh, get over here.
Oh, it's here.
I have to jump.
My holy bullets and grenades will solve this.
What's up, fucking?
Oh, shit.
The goddamn nerds Backshot Oh my god, I had to parkour Yeah
The holy hand grenades Blessed by gods
I wanna kill this guy
Wait, am I supposed to go Yeah Yeah No, that's where I came
from.
Is that where I came from?
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where did I come from?
I've jumped too many times.
I...
Did I come from?
I'm disoriented.
Is this the...
Is this where I came from or is this where I...
I'm lost.
I don't remember where I came from.
This is where I came.
This is the way.
Okay, this was the way.
No longer lost.
Good news, everybody.
There is a tank in front of me, but I'm no longer lost.
But I can take this tank.
Get out of the tank.
Just get out of here.
Get out of here.
All right.
My tank now.
That's fucking right.
Am I supposed to go?
Oh, shit.
Where I said I'll use the needle.
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Wait, what?
Oh, I have to do this again.
Get out of here!
My tank!
I want this tank!
Bro, my slaps hurt, apparently.
No.
No!
Who was it?
What the fuck?
He's like, I'm not letting you in this car.
Oh, shit!
What?
Okay, round two.
I'll get my tank someday.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
Which way was it?
Okay, here you go.
We got it.
We figured it out.
Okay, it's fine.
That's a very scary gun, but it's fine.
Oh my god, please be a little faster.
It was not fast.
It's okay, checkpoint.
Checkpoint, no.
You know what?
I actually want.
I want this.
Where's that car?
Wait, what happened to that car?
Wait, what happened to it?
Oh my god, it just drove away.
Oh my god.
Whatever.
I didn't want it anyway.
Who cares about it?
Did I actually destroy it?
Okay, I did it.
It's alright.
Who cares about it?
I'll just take this tank, I guess.
Tank, fight!
Oh my god, I can't...
Oh!
I don't remember how to shoot the other gun.
I remember there was another gun, but I don't remember how
to shoot it.
Oh, there were like 20 people with swords anyway.
It's all right.
Hey, guys.
Get over here.
You know what?
I'm not even gonna shoot the grenade.
You just take one slap.
Hello?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, I can't with this one.
Okay, that's...
Alright, get over here.
Yeah, I had a feeling that was gonna happen.
Get out of here.
Holy shit!
The driver's...
The car is self-driving!
Oh my god, the ghost is haunted!
Is this...
I...
Where is the...
Where is the entrance?
Where...
where is the entrance i don't know i can't see fucking shit
oh my god it was here get over here invisible time i would
drone the ghost in if i wasn't getting chased by 200 people
oh oh see-through glass
all right feels very safe now yay we made it
glass scary when your glass isn't see-through
more humans they must be after the icon I'm still not at the
there's no way that was the library I On your way, Arbiter.
I'll deal with these beasts.
Don't worry.
I'll be back.
I said that coward didn't join you.
I'll do what I can to keep the flood off your back.
I'm a coward.
He's fending off the parasite.
How dare you?
See, my men are still alive.
Am I not supposed to run past her?
I was not going to fight them.
There were like 500,000 people out there in one arbiter.
Like, what the fuck?
I have a shotgun?
Like, um...
I have a shotgun.
Shotgun?
I don't know what to do about those guys.
Oh, now I'm in the library.
That cow from Tartars has said from safety of his ship.
Yeah, oh my god, you're right.
Oh, right, they're here.
They're below me.
They're right below me, aren't they?
I should help out.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Okay, baby, taking a shotgun to the face was not the
smartest thing I've done today.
Stone man.
Okay, but now I know where they're coming.
Maybe I shouldn't.
He just went, pop.
Pop ahead.
The parasite gathers for an attack.
Pop.
I didn't know.
the good old shotgun blood okay i can't do about these guys
though like all i have is a shotgun
oh did they dock they dock
all right so
i don't like get shot at what the somebody died with honor
Don't worry!
Your sacrifice won't be invaded!
Don't worry.
His sacrifice.
Gosh, whoa!
That's a lot of swords.
Did you just...
Look, he died with honor.
He was running at them!
He knew!
the strat i sticky him he runs into them it's a tale as old
as time it's warstrat 101.
you think he was gonna live regardless at least he took
people down with him
yeah he knew what what he wanted to do i just sped up the
process
at least lied to his family he sacrificed himself with honor
that is not a lie friends like you needs enemies solid
thinking with a super chat thank you thank you that is not a
lie he sacrificed himself for the greater good.
Oh, hey.
Shikada, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, gosh.
That's a shotgun.
It's too late.
I already swung my fucking...
Oh, my God.
I already swung my sword.
It was too late.
I could...
Stop it
Okay, where am I?
All right, we're gonna have to watch this guy die because I
have to sticky him Because you guys should start using my
gun And where's the last guy?
okay I'm I was like maybe I should just stop just swinging
me first though I
hear you me first look
up it's just it's just the fucking okay what is he gonna I
thought he was gonna help he is not helping
Oh my god, this is the longest elevator ride in my life.
Oh, they're coming.
Maybe?
Yeah, oh, never mind.
Okay, that's just one guy, though.
That's not a very idea.
Okay, there you go.
Now you help.
Thank you.
I literally thought I would stick to them, but I guess not.
You're not...
Hello, sir?
Sir, there's still one more.
Oh!
There's not just one more!
It's not just one!
Apparently it was not just one more.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, now I can see.
Hello, sir.
all right nice we made it okay I know for sure there was no
bug on me but okay he's down there all right there see he's
helping now I'm just gonna wait for him to shoot these two
guys that's just chilling down there you think they okay he
is definitely not shooting them he's definitely not hitting
those shots
Oh, wait, we made it.
Oh, my God.
Finally made it.
We docked.
There's always more, one more.
That old familiar feeling.
Oh, my God.
Am I in the library?
Is that why?
Be a little cocky now.
They're like, you guys remember this?
Doesn't it feel so familiar?
Oh, y'all.
I remember this.
Oh, I do.
I do remember to get these little popcorn fuckers out of
here.
I do remember this.
Oh.
And they were right.
They were right.
Lost.
Oh my god, wrong way.
I'm fucking... I don't know.
I was just following a path.
Oh my god, I've lost the path.
I don't remember which way I was following.
I wanted a little circle.
Oh, right here.
Right here.
Just like old times.
Just like old times You
know you're sorry never asked me for help either the index
is secure We did it McKenzie Perez how's our exit You hear
me Marines Well, you got trouble oh
Shit oh my god Our paths are crossing.
How you doing?
My two personalities are finally meeting with each other.
Johnson, you all right?
Johnson!
Killer!
Okay, I would feel like that...
I feel like that punch would have literally just snapped her
neck.
Like, just from the sheer force of, like, you know...
The physio of the fucking Arbiter.
Like, I feel like her neck would have just fucking snapped.
Like...
And the Prophet's learn of this.
They will take...
Trader!
Fool.
They ordered you to do it.
What?
They're trading?
wait what but i believed i prayed i used my prayer bullets
oh okay now i'm with the tentacle monsters back to john halo
there's a glitch they like how someone really left that uh
man screen then they give us super chat thing thing
Graemite.
That's a lie.
Everything I do is for the greater good.
But not for him.
Wait, Arbiter?
Oh shit!
I'd rather not piss this thing off.
Demon.
This one is mission and...
his mind concluded this one is but flesh and faith and is
the more i wonder if they made any like parodies of this but
do not waste my time with talk there is get me out kill me
so i don't have to see this demon anymore through rock and
metal and time now i shall What do you mean, dirty?
Oh my god, you and I, both trapped.
And I went here.
Just you, dog.
I am the prophet of regret.
Wait, regret?
I thought I killed him.
At last, we have much to do.
This facility must be activated if we are to control this
outbreak.
Stay where you are.
until my sermon is complete.
Not true.
This installation has a successful utilization record of 1.2
trillion simulated in one actual.
It is ready to fire on demand.
Of all the objects our Lords left behind, there are none so
worthless as these oracles.
They know nothing of the Great Journey.
And you know nothing about containment.
You have demonstrated complete disregard for even the most
basic protocols.
containment.
And this one's great journey are the same.
Your prophets have promised you freedom from a doomed
existence.
But you will find no salvation on this ring.
Those who built this place knew what they wrought.
Do not mistake their intent.
all will perish as they did before this thing is right halo
is a weapon your prophets are making a big mistake your
ignorance already destroyed one of the sacred rings demon it
shall not harm another if you will not hear the truth then i
will show it to you there is still time to stop
You will search one likely spot.
And kiss is how I met your mother.
Fate have us meet as foes.
But this ring will make us brothers.
We are all of us gravely concerned.
The release of the parasite was unexpected, unfortunate.
There is no need to panic.
In truth, this is a time to rejoice.
A moment that all the covenants should savor.
For the sacred icon has been found.
With it, our path is clear.
Our entry into the divine beyond guaranteed.
The great journey is nigh and nothing.
Not even the flood can stop it.
Oh.
Unless.
Kill the demon.
How the fuck did I get here?
Wait, what?
Okay, con...
Wait.
Wait, I went into...
I have one gun.
Okay, guys, I have...
I put my flashlight on.
I...
I was like, did I get...
I fucking got...
Went into the holes?
I just accepted.
I was like, well, now I'm here.
He's like, I'll show you.
Now I'm here.
All right.
The teleporter.
He was a teleporter.
Even I was like, what the fuck happened?
Why do I have one gun?
Okay.
He's like, I will show you.
I was like, oh man, what is he going to show me?
I wonder.
Oh.
That's what he was going to show me.
I guess.
What?
Oh Shit that Oh now I know But take them out before It's
berserking
Okay It's berserking I'll stay up here
It was truly was oh my god I missed the cloak guys I really
missed having a cloak right now
There you go.
The demon has infiltrated the council chamber.
Protect the hierarchs.
Seal the exits.
Oh, I don't think so.
Alright.
Yay, I survived.
Wait, what is this?
I should be able to use this fucking knife.
What the fuck?
By the way, there is another one of those classic levels
that exclusive 2000 rock music that only pops up in
classics.
Oh!
Oh my god.
God, I thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just looked away for one second.
Just one second.
No, I really do miss the teleporting.
I miss having the teleporting.
I miss having the cloak cast.
It was pretty nice.
I will say, it was really nice.
Jesus these brutes they have so much oh no they're
berserking they're berserking they're berserking oh my god
they're getting very angry okay there you go the adrenaline
got too high
all right let's see we definitely need new ammo
Did they take headshots?
I don't even know if they have heads right now.
I don't even know.
It's just our body.
Wait, what?
Cover!
Okay, they do.
I should have just aimed for the head.
Well, now I know.
Now I know.
Their helmet just blends up perfectly, guys.
oh my god okay i'll get rid of these guys first
okay now i know that they can take headshots this makes it a
lot easier
yeah that does make it a lot oh all right we made it put me
down on one of the pedestals near the door one of the
pedestals where is the door i'm sorry this i'm still getting
used to their alien technology what is considered a door to
these aliens what what is the door here oh there we go i
found it there are so many doors i just don't know which one
is the actual door he has the index you've got to take it
from him let me get there's so many doors Cortana's always
listening guys all right that one's brave I don't know about
the other one though who are you naming oh there yeah
oh shit okay I did not expect that
oh it's
just like oops all doors Oh my god.
Oh!
I mean, at least it's easier to nade them when they dive
straight at me.
It's the little things.
One of them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Thank you, Cortana.
Oh, Cortana.
Cortana.
I'm gonna ask if he didn't.
You know, it's just saying, right this way.
You could have also said, by the way, There's people on the
other side.
That...
That would have been very helpful.
Nope.
I don't know where he's berserking to.
There we go.
Okay, that is like 20 headshots.
I made it.
Oh.
You still made it.
Oh!
Okay, it's just a little bit.
Yes, I got scared that I was the it's just oh my god.
Okay, and they don't stop coming All right now oh
What what what oh
Okay, oh watch out.
Okay, okay all right Watch out watch out john
Thanks.
Thanks, Cortana.
Man.
Thank God you told me just in time before I went down there.
Ooh, thank God.
Thank God Cortana told me just in time.
The lower levels of the tower.
I'll reverse this grab lift.
If you don't want to pick up that red gun.
What will we do about Kurt?
I feel so safe.
Oh.
Feel so very safe.
Okay, that is not fair.
Like, he's literally...
Okay.
He literally has a bodyguard!
Oh, I still shot him.
I didn't even realize I still killed him.
I do.
I don't want the sniper.
I love the sniper.
I'm not a fan of the grenade launcher.
I just don't know when to use it.
Slay the demon on sight.
They're beating up their patrol.
So sharp.
Oh.
There you go.
The fuck you survived the headshot?
I don't miss.
Oh.
Alright, nice.
I love the sniper.
I'm going to use the sniper for the brutes and then the...
And the regular gun for everything else.
Okay, sorry.
I...
Oh, come on!
It sucked me!
surprised me.
Oh my god, I still used it.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, my entire plan is in shambles.
My entire plan is in shambles.
Okay, I'm, I'm already dead.
Like, what do you want from me?
I had an entire plan.
Jeez, is that?
Are you serious?
Woo!
Oh my god, he's ruining the plan.
My plan has so much structure.
He's dead, right?
There you go.
God damn stupid needles.
Alright, there's still one more little guy.
I saw him.
Where is he?
Oh, there you are.
I remember seeing you Rido Plan A is now plan B
Oh, what the fuck oh shit, oh what the fuck I can't push
that's illegal I truly am these people's boogeyman Wait,
which one's Okay, there you go.
Oh, it's back here.
It's back here.
Oh, I did not get a checkpoint.
Oh, I could do this again.
I'm just gonna get out of here.
Gavin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
Oh, my plans are shambles.
Okay.
It's okay.
it out.
Alright.
You're not worried.
I figured everything out again.
I'm reading Marine IS somewhere below your position.
Oh, now they give me a...
That's so bullshit!
They are!
They did ambush me!
Oh my god.
That was so bullshit.
They were... It was an ambush all of them.
alive.
There you go.
Hey, I think that's his head?
I don't...
It's so hard to see us.
Such a tiny head.
Sorry, I'm here to prove their little ghost stories were
real!
There's another lift in the next room.
Is that sniper?
No, that's just carbine around.
There's another room?
Ritana might be easier to tell me how many rooms are left.
I just assume it's all rooms at this point.
It's just all rooms.
Where did they go?
Wait, where did he go?
I mean, I'll take those.
Hello?
Brutes?
Brutes!
Oh, brutes!
Where did they go?
Hmm, it's a little suspicious.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
Oh, fuck!
That's really...
Oh, wait!
I fucking...
I fucking knew it.
I was like, hmm, that's weird.
That's weird.
They're brutes, though.
How are they strategizing?
I don't understand.
Where do they even fit that in their tiny little skulls?
Okay, now that I know their plan.
Oh, I see you.
I fucking see you.
Oh, my God.
Trying to kill you.
Stand still.
Stand still for me.
I'm trying to kill you.
Okay, what the fuck?
What is going on?
Hurry up.
I'm just gonna hope that he doesn't charge underneath.
I'm just gonna hope.
All right.
Ratano?
There's 20 space doors.
Cortana.
Which one is it?
Oh, wait, that's a sniper.
Oh, there we go.
It's this space door.
It's the space slide, apparently.
Over there.
Mind telling what you're doing with this bird?
Alpharius, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Neutralize.
Threat neutralize.
I did it, guys.
Quietly.
Hey, they didn't say for how long.
I was quiet for...
At least one second.
So I did my job.
They only told me to do it.
They didn't say for how long I was supposed to do it for it.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
It's just...
It's just awesome.
One more bullet.
Wee.
I had the okay if I'm gonna die taking you down with me I
used the wrong gun I just realized and not mean to use the
sniper but
I hate the ricochet when they hit me it's so annoying that's
right I cornered myself there
you go is that every everybody oh it's just this guy left
come on get over here get over oh oh oh all right now now
we're really gaming all right checkpoint done get out of
here get out of here get out of here
why in like a prison all right down i go Wee!
Oh shit, we don't know.
Like, where is, where are they?
Oh shit, he's right behind me, isn't she?
Where's the baba duke?
Oh, goodbye!
Down I go.
Up I go?
It's like Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
Whoops.
Oh.
And then John Halo comes up behind you.
Whoops.
Okay, I need you to turn your fucking head up.
Oh my god.
I need him to...
I need him to turn around.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to headshot if he doesn't give me his
head?
Like, please, make it easier for me to kill you.
Oh my god, that was a Kobe.
No head?
Alright, at least I cleared the wave down there.
So now I can go down.
Wee.
Oh, that's for carbine.
Where was it?
It was right here.
Our katana.
Open.
Okay, apparently it was not right here.
It was up there.
Oh, what the fuck?
Space bugs.
Ew.
Guys, you have some pesticide.
You guys might need some space pesticide.
It's right here.
Alright, now I have checkpoint.
It's so weird.
Sometimes I have checkpoint and sometimes I don't.
I really did not expect them to...
all right only because i know i he was the only one left
what why did this oh oh my god i almost shot him i only oh
it's this oh there we go one more group of marines to go
yeah i need you okay marines take take the rocket marines oh
my god you have rockets you have aliens space rockets and
you still want to take that gun you
have so many choices
all right well then
oh seven oh seven we free them just for them to die in this
You're not truly free when you're with John Halo.
There you go.
That should be all of this.
Nice.
Gonna get this guy.
Oh my god, just goddamn stupid shield.
Fuck this.
Wait, his ship blocks rocket?
What kind of gun?
We got sealed this alien technology.
Well, if this don't wake you up, nothing will.
Okay, he didn't...
Okay, buddy.
Now you're gonna be helpful.
Okay, maybe I fucked up.
Maybe I fucked up a little there.
I need you to be...
I need to stop wasting bullets on dead bodies right now.
We have very limited ammo.
There we go.
Now we have more people.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I mean, I guess he was in prison.
He was in prison.
He has a lot of unresolved trauma.
This is the wrong species to be double-tapping for.
Oh, okay.
The sentry.
Oh, whoa!
Okay, I thought that was the rockets.
Oh, shit!
There we go.
Holy shit, that guy is taking four rockets to the face.
Just letting it out.
Wee.
Surely not this left.
What?
the fuck what am i looking what am i looking at right now
it's like a little oh okay there we go
oh i should have made it that actually
there you go nice needed more of that Yeah, I was just like,
are they doing their own little bouncy castle?
What's going on over there?
We did it.
Fear not, my brothers.
The sacred item is secure.
That's truth.
I really want to use the knife, but...
Should I keep the rocket launcher?
I'm going to keep the car button for the headshots.
Actually, I forgot to keep the...
I'm gonna keep the rockets.
I'm gonna keep the rockets
All right, they should all right, I'm gonna keep the rockets
Oh There we go What we're still alive.
Oh, these guys
Oh All right now chop chop chop chop chop chop wait chop
holy shit he needs a double chop i'm barely reached skin
oh oh no oh no oh no
he's berserking okay i don't know how to chop but get over
here oh no Wait, all my prisoners are...
Oh, no, please don't tell me my prisoners are...
Chop!
Sky chop!
Oh.
It's like a fly swat.
I know, I feel like I'm swatting flies right now.
I should have kept my carbide.
Wait, I think I still have the carbide back there.
I'm gonna be right back, guys.
Just stay there.
A fly swat, you're here.
I think that's his head.
Maybe it'll be easier to see.
Oh yeah, no, it would be easier to see.
Shiner in the OG.
They are shinier in the OG, thank God.
It was never a rescue operation.
I just needed more meat shields.
When the fuck did I kill him have failed to protect the
prophets and in so doing put all our lives at risk wait
that's guilt-tripping hey he's guilt-tripping them whilst we
find the power i've got a fix on truth just outside this
tower there's an exit nearby hurry there might be like
katana would be like where are all the prisoners that we
just freed um they got lost I mean they love they they just
love living here that they didn't want to come with me
Cortana I couldn't convince them to to leave they just
really wanted to stay
like what could I do Cortana I tried so hard to convince
them
you're like we can rebuild we can rebuild the covenant Make
it our own.
You think he knew?
Do you think he saw me?
Oh yeah, no, he definitely saw me.
I don't know if I can loop this.
Bro, how many backshots do you take?
Wee.
Wee!
The tango.
Bro, fuck this.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck!
As many as you can tell.
Okay, I like the little the whimsical song, the whimsical
music for this.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
I'm fucking trying to juke this cat.
I just need to pull Agra on one of them.
Alright, we'll do this again in this tiny hole.
It might not be, like, the most idea.
Okay, I go two of them.
I will do it here.
This might be easier.
Get over here.
I fucked up.
I fucked up the job.
Wait, it's...
Here we go.
Stuff like this.
It's not gonna turn around, right?
Get sticky.
Oh.
Get sticky?
Oh!
Are you serious?
That doesn't kill him.
I chopped him.
Oh, my God.
He chopped me.
All right.
Round two.
I...
I'm just body-blocking myself.
I don't think...
I don't think the arm...
I don't think my knife can chop through that, apparently.
I...
Apparently, my knife cannot...
I don't know how to insert my knife through the gap.
I just keep...
I put it on Rosasso instead of Veridica.
I don't know how to poke with my knife apparently I just
know how to slash it looks like why isn't it fitting I don't
understand the square does not go into the the circle hole
no one knew how to how to teach him how to poke I'm just
gonna run past this I don't have the guns for this
I'll just casually walk past all of this.
Oh,
I should have just done this.
Oh, I should have just done this in the first place.
Oh, all right.
I didn't know I could have just walked past all of that.
That was a good strat.
their fleet creatures of the covenant the path is broad and
we shall walk it side by side oh yeah flip space rupture
it's in amber cloud good thing there's a silver worm right
now did not could just walk past the entire encounter
instead of going doing a little oh my god i keep like
reflexing reflex trying to
oh wait they're fighting each other that's good well now
they're fighting me because i killed everybody what the well
your team is there is a civil war and you still want like we
hate you more than we hate them like clearly holy shit look
up look up at what what am i looking at it's just alien
spaceship.
Yeah, Third Hatred united the team.
Oh, I missed it?
What was it?
I was getting shot at.
Guys.
You missed it.
Don't worry.
Guys, I was getting shot at.
There was a war going on.
Guys, I don't think people at Normadine when they stormed
the beach they're like look up soldier look at this
beautiful ocean beach that that was storming right now I
don't think that was the first thing they thought of I think
I'm just gonna run sweet it'll be a shame if I okay yep I
need it I'm gonna shit up
okay all right guys there's like other stuff to worry about
what's
the fucking worry about all right they're fighting each
other now all right nice they made it you know what me first
me first oh shit not this one too
i'm trying to let them fight but they're Looking at me for
some reason.
What the fuck?
How are you still?
There is a spacebar!
Oh my god.
There is literally a spacebar going on right now with your
team.
Your team needs help.
Okay, apparently they did not.
They did not need help.
They were absolutely fine.
Never mind.
All right, at least I have a recharge.
All right, that's fine.
I need more ammo for this anyway.
What gun is this?
Oh, it's just three bullets.
Okay, how am I going to deal with this guy?
Can I...
I can't kill him through that.
Um, he didn't...
He did not...
He did not go through the portal, and so...
Little concern about that.
I don't think I can reach that.
I might be John Halo, but my arm is not...
Does not go that far.
Alright.
Okay, now that works.
He didn't shoot back this time.
I mean, that works too.
Oh.
That's stupid.
Cast down the elites.
There are those who said this day would never come.
What are they to say now?
Oh, I'm stupid.
Once the towers are cleared, we'll drive them from the lower
districts.
I'll wait for them to have their little fight first.
I'll sit here.
Hydrate.
There we go.
All right, they're still fighting.
I need them to get rid of the bugs.
No!
Nope, nope!
Not me!
I'm not the one you're supposed to be shooting at.
I need to reload.
Oh, nice.
They're shooting each other now.
That's good.
I'm just gonna casually walk past this.
All right.
Gonna walk past the whole fight here.
Nice.
Third party successful.
Wait, they're actually all dead.
Let's go!
Grab some of your ammo.
He's like, I did it!
Oh, classic?
It was just like, we did it, guys!
We won the war!
I was like, I won the war.
Alright, here we are.
Yeah, another checkpoint done.
Oh, is that the sniper?
Where is the arbiter?
Did the arbiter go into the portal with me?
Like, where did he go?
the brutes oh they're chasing the little guy all right i'll
just walk past everybody i guess
i was gonna say we both went into the same hole well yeah we
came through different ways oh next mission okay i'll stay
here because i was gonna say where did the arbiter go Oh,
truth.
I'm coming for you, truth.
Oh, I'm coming for you.
How many shots did I take?
It took a... It did... Okay, I don't know why I thought I
could take him.
I... I don't know.
I just thought I was built different, I guess.
I really thought I was just built different.
Is he running at me?
He was.
There we go.
Alright, Truth, I'm gonna get you.
I'm gonna get you.
I'm gonna jump, jump.
Alright.
I'll fight the winner.
Alright, guys.
Come on.
There we go.
Come on, guys.
I said I'll fight the winner.
when oh my god i was getting sniped in the back the entire
time all right now wait which way is this way all right now
i've okay i know where you are sniper that's fucking oh
you're safe you think you're safe so i can get your ass out
of here oh wait shortcut shortcut
I don't know where I'm heading But I assume this is a
shortcut Oh it is a shortcut Let's go Shortcut
Oh he doesn't know where he's getting shot from Okay I think
he knows now
Alright we're fighting each other I can sneak right through
They'll never expect a thing
They'll never expect me yeah okay nice this is oh fuck what
dog me first what oh me first all right I'll never expect me
where am I supposed to go
oh my god there's 20 of them oh i should not have killed all
the cloak guys
no i shouldn't have killed all of them wait where am i okay
i need to figure out where to go i am directionless yet
again i'm just gonna assume they'll chop each other okay
little guys get out of here get out of here i found a way
the little guys showed me the way all right we did it oh so
peaceful in here oh the brutes haven't penetrated this base
yet I'm supposed to walk past through everything.
Oh, I forgot.
I have a sniper.
I appreciate them running away.
Alright, I just have to keep chopping.
It's garden season.
Gotta take out the weeds.
Yeah, I'll grab the carbine.
too many little guys.
Okay, I got grabbed a sniper.
Now there's big guys.
Oh my, now there's little guys again.
Guys, you guys gotta...
Alright, now...
Oh, now I have a rocket cannon.
Let's go.
Oh, and now there's no one.
Now, now, alright.
Now they're all just gone.
Now...
The moment I grab all right and now they're all just gone
that's fine
it's like magic it's like fucking magic every time i open
the door something new shows up are you fucking kidding me
every time all right i swear to god i If I open this door,
I, then it's their god.
And their fucking god.
Is there a repeat in itself?
Okay, that should, like, fully blow him up, right?
Where's the other guy?
I know there was one more.
There you go.
Alright, now.
And now.
all dead.
Where's the car button?
There it is.
Okay, they were not all dead.
They were not all dead.
Alright, now that they're all dead.
He's just gonna stay there so I can just be spamming that.
How the fuck are you able to Chuck needs further than me!
They're fucking grunts!
Where the fuck did he get that arm enhancement?
Alright, should be all of them.
We know how to look up.
Oh, I went here to the other side.
I did not realize... I did not realize that Jackal is...
Oh, with the brutes.
Damn, this really is a class system.
For the...
The jackals are...
There's no way the jackals are lower tier than the brutes.
Or than the grunts.
That is not...
I did not realize that...
I didn't even know I'm here.
I didn't even know now.
It's okay.
I'll just...
past them here.
Surely they're not coming for me, right?
Surely not.
If I... Okay, guys.
Okay.
The speed runs fast.
I'll wait a little longer.
I know they seem much more interested in killing each other.
I almost got away, too.
I'll wait for them to go closer.
I'm just surprised that, like, like, the grunts are higher
tier than the jackals.
You would think it's the other way around, you know?
I would think that jackals would have...
Oh, my God.
They turned around.
They didn't like that I was looking.
Yeah, I thought the jackals would be on the elite side, and
then the grunts would be on the brute side with how much
they get bullied.
I guess the grunts are way too stupid to understand How they
mistreated Yeah, yeah, I was gonna say I guess they are too
stupid to They're so low tier that they just I was just a
firing squad
They was sad with the sun Hey guys, I'm just gonna run past
all of you guys and then hope to god you will turn back
around it works somehow you turn back around guys it somehow
worked my plan
goodbye yeah i don't know what plan b is after that I didn't
think I'd...
Oh, no.
I did not mean to go up here.
Alright.
I swapped.
Am I just supposed to live?
Oh my god.
There's no checkpoint.
There's no checkpoint at all.
Wait, they're fighting each other.
I'll wait.
I can wake this out.
They're fighting each other.
Let's go.
The most intense fight ever They're coming for me They're
coming for me
Not as intense as I thought I didn't realize they would lose
so fast
Okay I have one issue
Okay Okay My biggest concern right now is what the fuck am I
gonna do with the big bug boys?
What?
That's my main concern.
I don't think I have a weapon that can deal with the...
I don't know.
I just have little carbines.
fuel rod gun do i have one where is it oh it's down here is
this a fuel rod gun no that's just a regular plasma gun oh
god oh god one of the least had it i don't know where it is
oh no oh no I want to do the spin trick, but there's so
many!
There it is.
The fuel rod cannon.
Oh, shit, nice.
Here we go.
We did it.
Oh my god, we did it.
We survived.
I don't know how, but we did it.
Hang on.
I'm picking up two more transponders.
It's the commander and Johnson.
They're closing on truth.
Oh my god, they're here.
Reinforcements arrive.
And we used to call the Fiorat, the Snodder Cannon.
The name of the Super Chat, Steve, is it easy?
Thank you, thank you, we did it.
We survived.
Oh.
Okay, guys, guys, come on.
Guys, come on.
We're safe!
Oh, yes!
Wait, which way was the...
Where am I?
How do I get it?
Okay.
I'm perpetually just lost all the time.
Oh, this goddamn stupid guy.
She did not...
Oh my god, that...
Oh my, goodbye!
Truth!
in the hole now that i know wait is it the other way no he
comes oh my god he comes out that way wrong hole you
could just go invisible he's right
all right i was gonna say that better like straight up kill
him
Oh my god, I hit myself.
Boom!
Slash, no!
I thought I could slash him first.
They come through this hole.
That's right, plan.
How did she know?
I lived this timelines before.
That's right.
I've been stuck in the loop.
How many more do I have seven bullets?
That's enough.
All right.
Halo meets Groundhog Day.
How did he know he truly is the demon?
He could tell the future.
No, did they know this is not the first John Halo.
This is John Halo 533.
We gotta rescue them.
hopes of all the covenant rest on your shoulders chieftain
my faith is strong i will not fail
oh my god stowaways don't get inside him
let him be the great journey awaits for no one brother not
even you What?
Oh my gosh, so now he can take over everything.
The portrayal!
I don't even remember who was the other guy.
Damn, now he has all the power.
Was that mercy?
Damn, mercy wasn't shown any mercy.
Can't believe it.
He was like, this is it.
this is my time now he has full control only truth remains
oh there's where where did the arbiter got dropped up an
effort for truth is i already know it's all it's all lies
anyway all right guys i want to know how many missions do i
have left
The worm gave me one gun.
Thanks, worm.
To be fair, I'm surprised I was able to grab a gun from the
worm's mouth.
Three more?
Wait, is this the last one?
Should I save this for next stream?
Three including this one?
Three left.
How long is the last three?
all right we'll save this for the last stream because some
people might be like oh no i was hoping to watch that in
stream for halo so i want to make sure everyone gets a
chance to watch halo all right not long all right last
stream will be next date last halo stream oh if i knew that
i could just fucking completed this today i mercy cat die
blizzard will go bankrupt with no skins this thinking I'll
end it in my own means goodbye you can't take me alive oh it
was all just a horrible dream it was on as I'm gonna call it
here it was a lot it was the shortest stream today um I I
didn't know I couldn't tell if I was if I was able to finish
this game today or Saturday so that's why I didn't want to
risk it because I looked at like I do this thing when I try
to figure out if I'm gonna finish a game or not um if I if
like a stream is gonna be finished or not and I looked up
like no commentary like I don't see the actual playthrough
of it I just want to know where my mission where I ended at
I always look at where I ended at and I see how much
remaining time I have left and I was like hmm it says here
it's like four hours left But I'm like, but what is four
hours and doki hours?
And then so I was like, in doki hours, it might be two
streams.
So I was just like, hmm.
So that's why I placed it into two streams.
But if I knew, I would have made it this stream.
I would have made this stream as like the last Halo stream.
But we still have Saturday to finish it up.
To be fair, I like ran through everything because I was
like, why am I fighting this?
Like, what's the point?
What am I proving?
Like, you have your own civil war to go through.
Like, I'm just, I was just like, this is your civil war.
I have nothing to prove here.
I just, bye.
I'll see you guys.
We'll see who the winner is next time.
Terminator.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ward, ward, ward.
Hey, guys.
I, uh...
I'm gonna go rest now.
I can tell my voice is starting to die anyway.
So it's a good thing that I didn't try and finish it today.
Just because, like, I do need to rest my throat.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up from me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys on next time, everybody.
Either tomorrow for members or on Saturday for the last part
for Halo.
Hey, guys.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye.
saw Arbiter and John Halo all like, you know, tangled up
with the with the tentacle monster in my head.
I was like, oh no, John Halo, we're both stuck in that room
together.
I hope nothing bad happens to us.
Oh.